alright so we're taking a look at
nisha's action skill right now her
actions girl has showdown yeah showdowns
this kind of cowgirl promise that Nisha
has when you activate you go into this
spaghetti western mode we have the sepia
tone and this really cool music and you
you target the critical spots on all the
enemies around but you do have to be
active in it because you hold that left
trigger and you flick between enemies
try and take out as many as you possibly
can yeah I mean especially if you're
using something cool like like a Jacob's
revolver you're going to be pulling that
trigger non-stop and you're going to be
kind of fanning between all of your and
all of the enemies available well it's
really cool though is that we have
skills that will allow you to stretch
out so you can be in showdown four
minutes yeah the more kills you get the
longer it's it's going to last all right
now we're taking a look at the law and
order tree and this is a really
interesting tree because the kind of
focus on the idea of pain and gain that
is sort of give and take in combat as
nisha takes damage in some of these
areas she can actually become stronger
either dealing more damage and return or
even getting her shield back this also
kind of focuses on her bull web which is
her melee ability yeah and this is the
first time we've actually had a long
distance melee weapon in Borderlands
this is also the fan the hammer tree
which focuses much more on on pistols
and what's really cool about the
capstone skill and this one is that
she's able to duplicate her pistol and
essentially guns urk yeah but the really
cool thing about this is it's for the
rest of the game once you have this
capstone if you have a pistol you then
duplicate to have two pistols for the
rest of the entire game very cool and
the last skill tree is the rifle woman
this is very much our sort of classic
cowboy concept you know it's all about
run-and-gun hipfire headshots a lot of
fun we're think today though we're going
to focus on the law and order skill tree
yeah I think Lauren order really shows
some of knishes personality you know she
she kind of takes a bit of pleasure in
taking that pain and dealing it back to
the bad guys it's also very flashy
because as
is getting her orders to action being
from taking damage these sheriff badge
icons will pop up on the screen and
whenever use our capstone course with
her melee she'll do this massive shock
damage to enemies and it just lights up
the room very nice looks great very cool
alright now we're going to hit the
ground running people that have seen the
e3 demo will remember that Jack has been
working with a boy named tickle the
health and find a military AI yeah this
is a direct continuation of our e3 demo
and we've made our way finally to the
drakensberg which is this derelict doll
ship that's crashed here and we've been
given information that there is a
military AI in here being held by a guy
called the bosons and he's being helped
by another personal to skipper and
they're going to stop us at least try
and stop us from getting their military
because it's what's keeping the ship
running right and they're able to
effectively stopped us because they have
an army of scabs better at their
disposal but what are scabs well the
scabs are these X doll engineers who
came down to mind elpis years ago before
the Kraken but when the crackling
happened on Elvis doll abandoned them
and they can stuck here and they've been
scavenging and you know they've got a
bit stir-crazy but there that may do and
then one of them to living in the
drakensberg ship right now so they don't
want you to come and steal the military
i even though jack needs it to power up
his loaders yeah they don't seem too
keen by our presence
very cool now nisha just fed her cry Oh
slam her Oscar I was really cool I think
want my favorite things about the
pre-sequel is that you're able to freeze
enemies and shatter them just look so
awesome yeah I mean the fact that we're
low gravity just makes it even more
beautiful when you share someone like HD
with a nipride whip right there you see
there I starts floating options in orbit
and we should just hit the this robber
what's our web and you can see that
there's a fairly long distance melee and
she was able to get a good shot going
weapon and you can see those sheriff
stars are coming up now which means that
she's been taking that damage and she
can then deal it back so she stalls that
up just to give it straight back to them
hey oh and your traditional combat
you're always kind of wanting to keep
you or your shields up and your help but
Aisha kind of kind of has some fun with
that concept because you want her to
take damage you know you don't want to
go down all the time but like you want
your you want to be taking hits because
it makes you more powerful yeah i think
our designs have actually had a lot of
fun taking the play character's
personality into their mind when they
designed their skills
what large groups what's really a great
ability as we're showing on because
she's having to clear it off really
quickly you know getting massive numbers
of fresh shots in a very short period of
time I mean she has me a short work of
those two scavs
oh we see a clap Trump in the distance
they're going to pirate ship mode he's
helping us out taking out some scabs
himself it was very nice nice good to
have a friend along especially someone
like Bob shot because he's very eager to
please definitely he'll take any friend
he can get
and you see the the scabs one of them
had a whole badge icon above his head
that's what kind of show like who's been
dealing damage to you and who you can
impact with because some of you show
skills focus on yeah she's a little bit
into revenge Nisha that's all right
though
yeah guys Austin for it I think oh yeah
I've been dealing quite a bit of damage
and that web just took his health down
cut by half which is really cool and
he's done
alright so heading inside the
drakensberg now they're probably not you
know waiting to hand over the military
or I first you know as nice as that
would be we're probably going to
encounter some resistance yeah that's
okay because I've got a really good
feeling about showdown in this room once
we get their attention shooting that
should be able to clear them all out
pretty quickly good slam that started
off with yep nice hey if I Kelly just
like 9i think three or four scabs right
there's very good he sure really likes
it coming to a room and clear it comes
from the opening door see if she can
shatter these enemies in time he
defrosted just in time to get shot yeah
I think it all worked out
and that was claptraps clapping the Box
skill right there in action people may
have known that he was walking by with
one of those like holds hey me bouncing
like a short that views on it very cute
that was huge amount of damage too short
then yeah and you know we're in true
vault hunter mode so enemies here are
going to be tougher they're also going
to deal a lot more damage and what the
way that nisha aspect out today that
actually works in our favor and you see
we're in oxygen at the moment so these
guys are going to maintain that burning
status
most like the person isn't just going to
give us the AI probably not on the top
of his priority list at the moment he's
probably going to get the skipper to try
and stop us I think well that's all
right because you know Nisha is very
powerful she's got five top to back her
up should be fine i think i think i
think they might be having some troubles
in their relationship as well the
skipper and the bosun so there's a
chance we may be out of sway a to our
side yeah the skipper might come in
handy
you
looks like the skin of the bosun had
sent some more enemies to come and try
to stop us let's get an Olsen slam in
here yep nice very nice these are just
cleared out all of the shields with our
bolognaise has just been clap trapped as
well uh-oh with the funds working
slam alright very cool I mean that sky
was I had a lot of helpful of silk
shizzle knock him out with that web
well it looks like the skipper may have
some reasons to help us after all
excellent
there
all right so it looks like we have a new
ally with the skipper she's going to
open the door for us and get us outside
and I think that's a great time for some
kind of wrap up this video thanks for
tuning in borderless of pre sequel comes
out and North America on october
fourteenth and it comes out October
sixteenth in Australia and october 17
the rest of the world thanks everyone by
becoming